welcome to the presentation on quadratic
inequalities i know that sounds very
complicated but hopefully you'll see
it's actually
not that difficult or at least maybe the
problems we're going to work on aren't
that difficult
well let's get started with some
problems and
hopefully you'll see where this is kind
of slightly different than solving
regular quadratic equations
so let's say i had the inequality
x squared
plus
3 x
is greater than 10.
and remember whenever you solve a a
quadratic or i guess we call it a second
degree equation i guess this is an
inequality i shouldn't use the word
equation
it's tempting to sometimes do it the
same way you do a linear equation kind
of getting all the x terms on one side
and all the constants on the other but
it never works because you actually have
an x term and then you have an x squared
term so you actually want to get it in
kind of what i would call the i don't
know if it's actually called this the
standard form where you actually have
all the terms on one side and then a
zero on the other side and you can
either factor it
or use the quadratic equation so let's
do that
well this is pretty easy we just have to
subtract 10 from both sides and we get
x squared plus
x
minus 10
is greater than zero
now let's see if we can factor it are
there two numbers when you multiply it
become negative 10 and when you add it
become
positive 3 well yeah positive 5 and
negative 2. and once again
at this point i think you already know
how to do factoring so this should be
pretty
hopefully obvious to you
so it's x
plus five
times
x
minus two
is greater than
zero
now this is the part where it's gonna
become a little bit more difficult than
just your traditional factoring problem
we have two numbers i guess you could
view it we have x plus five i view that
as one number or i guess we have two
expressions we have x plus 5
and we have x minus 2. and when we're
multiplying them we're getting something
greater than 0 right
now let's think about what happens when
you multiply numbers
if they're both positive and you
multiply them then you get a positive
number and if they're both negative and
you multiply them then you also get a
positive number right so we we know that
either both of these expressions are the
same sign that they're both greater than
zero they're both positive or we know
that they're both negative
right and i know this might be a little
confusing but just think of it as x
if if i told you that let me i'll do
something slightly separate out here if
i tell you that a times b
is greater than zero we know that
either
a is greater than 0
and b
is greater than 0 right
which just means that they're both
positive or
a is less than 0
and
b is less than zero
which means that they're both negative
right all we know is that they both have
to be the same sign in order for the
product to be greater than zero
and we just do the same thing here
so we know that either both of these are
positive so
x plus five
is greater than zero
and
x minus two is greater than zero
or right
or
now this is a little confusing but if
you work through these problems it
actually makes a lot of sense
or
they're both negative or x plus 5
is less than 0
and
x minus two is less than zero i know
that's confusing but just think of it in
terms of we have two expressions they're
either both positive or they're either
both negative right because when you
multiply them you get something larger
than zero
let's solve this side so this says that
x is greater than negative 5
and
x
is greater than
right because we just added 2 both sides
of this equation
or
and if we solve this side
x
is less than
whoops x is less than negative 5
and
x is less than 2 right i just solved
both of these inequalities right here
now we can actually simplify this
because here we say that x is greater
than negative 5
and x is greater than 2.
so in order for x to be greater than
negative 5
and for x to be greater than 2 this
could just simplify to saying well x is
just greater than 2 right because if x
is greater than 2 it's definitely
greater than negative 5. so it just
simplifies to this right
and we'd say or
and here we said x is less than negative
five or x is less than two well we know
if x is less than negative five then x
is definitely less than two so we could
just simplify it to
or x is less than negative five
so the solutions to this problem is x
could be greater than two
or x could be less than negative five
and so let's just think about how that
looks on the number line
so if 2 is here
x could be greater than 2 so it's all of
these numbers
right and if this is negative 5 i should
have done it so close to the bottom
this x
x is less than negative 5. so these are
the numbers
that satisfy this equation and i'll
leave it up to you to try out to see
that they they actually work
let's try another one and hopefully i
can confuse you even more
let's say i have
minus x
times
2x
minus 14
is greater than or equal to 24.
well the first thing we want to do is
just manipulate this so it looks in the
standard form so it gets we get
negative
x squared plus 14 x i'm just
distributing the minus x is greater than
or equal to 24.
i don't like a any coefficient in front
of my x squared term so let's divide
both sides of this equation by negative
so we get x squared right divided by
negative 2
minus 7x
and remember when you divide by a
negative number you switch the sign on
the inequality or you switch the
direction of the inequality so we're
dividing by negative 2 so we switched it
we went from greater than or equal to
less than or equal to and then 24
divided by negative 2 is minus 12.
and now we can just bring this minus 12
onto the left-hand side of the equation
add 12 to both sides we get
x squared minus seven x
plus 12
is less than or equal to zero
and then we can just factor that and we
get what is that it's x
minus three times
x
x minus 4 is less than or equal to 0.
so now we know that when we multiply
these two terms we get a negative number
so that means that these expressions
have to be of different signs
right does that make sense if i tell you
i have two numbers and i multiply them i
get a negative number you know that they
have to be of different signs so we know
that either
x minus three
is less than or equal zero
and
x minus four
is greater than or equal to zero so
that's one case
and the other case is
x minus three is greater than or equal
to zero which means x minus three is
positive
and
x minus four is less than or equal to
zero i went to the edge so let's solve
this and hopefully it'll simplify more
so this just says x is less than or
equal to 3
and this says
x
is greater than
or equal to 4 right so both of these
things have to be true x has to be less
than or equal to 3 and x
has to be greater than or equal to 4.
well let me ask you a question can
something be
both less than 3
less than or equal to 3 and greater than
or equal to 4 well no so we know that
this situation can't happen right
there's no numbers that's less than or
equal to 3 and greater than or equal to
4. so let's look at this situation this
says x
is greater than or equal to 3
and
x is less than or equal to 4.
can this happen sure that just means
that x is some number between 3 and 4.
if we were to draw this on the number
line
we would get
if this is 3
3 this is 4 and it's greater than or
equal to so we fill it in and less than
or equal to so we'd fill it in
and it would be any number between 3 and
4 would satisfy this equation and i'll
leave it up to you to try it out i know
this is confusing at first and this is
actually something that they normally
don't teach really well i think in most
high schools until 10th or 11th grade
but just think about you're multiplying
two expressions
if the answer is negative then they must
be of different signs if the answer is
positive they must be the same sign
and then you just work through the logic
and you say oh well no number can be
less than three and greater than four so
this doesn't apply and then you do this
side like oh this this situation does
work it's any number between three and
four
hopefully that gives you a sense of how
to do these type of problems i'll let
you do the exercises now have fun